what are you most worried about over the
next let's call it six to 12 months
what's the thing that you're like man
people really got to pay attention to
this and i don't think enough people are
paying attention to whether it's a risk
or a potential surprise on the horizon
so
people ask me every hour of the day
are we at the bottom is the time to buy
and we're not and the reason i say that
is
let's just talk crypto markets all
crypto markets i don't care what asset
class you're in within crypto markets
what coin what token what asset what
project
i don't care it doesn't matter we're not
at the bottom yet
what defines
a good bottom
is a panic event now we've had some good
bankruptcies but they're all small you
know this yesterday's announcement
voyager it's irrelevant it's so small
and so
decentralized in the sense that the the
shareholders are all over the place and
it's not really um
going to hurt anything and but
so it doesn't bring the panic bottom
that you need
what defines great bottoms is panic in
the streets massive capitulation massive
selling massive volatility and then you
flush it out that big toilet in the sky
has to flush
it's coming soon i feel it coming
somebody's offside somebody's over
levered these small guys going to zero
just never knew how to manage risk
because they'd never experienced
anything like this now the good news for
them is they've learned you know learn
grasshopper learn don't leverage
yourself up like that with an asset that
you can't ever peg the bottom on so they
got wiped out so what it's a great
learning experience for them they'll be
much better managers going forward and
the shareholders chalk it up to
entertainment no different than going to
las vegas you took that kind of chance
with leverage you got wiped out
learn that's the whole point but the big
event hasn't happened yet it's coming to
a theater near you shortly i don't know
who it's going to be
somebody's gnashing their teeth right
now somebody's way over leveraged
somebody's trying to borrow cash and
tomorrow morning you might find out who
it is i'm looking forward to that one
that's when you go back into the market
when it's absolute panic in the streets
and it will happen
when you think that we're at the bottom
which you claim that we are not yet
we'll see uh do you just take a slug of
cash and you're all in on one shot or do
you try to dollar cost average your way
in like what's your strategy whether
it's in crypto or just other markets in
general how do you normally think about
re-entering a market
yeah i've never been able to time the
bottom it's impossible so i've already
started to layer in uh primarily in
equities now because you know we're
still not at the bottom there either
because ps are still a little expensive
i anticipate if we could get down to
fifteen fifty and a half pe on the s p
then you can cherry pick the top hundred
you know highest quality balance sheets
in the s p 500 and that'd probably be a
good place to put some money to work and
you'd be layering in nobody knows about
the recession it's pretty hard to have a
recession to full unemployment you know
for employment i mean we don't have uh
you know any
this is not your typical recession i can
tell you that i haven't even seen any
results yet of private companies i've
invested in slowing down at all yet we
can't even hire anybody so we're in a
different kind of time right now and
we'll have to see where that goes but in
crypto you get a lot more volatility and
you know obviously the granddaddy asset
is bitcoin it's holding its own at 20
000
but if you saw that spike down in a
panic sell-off that somebody had to off
their coin because they're you know
being margin called out and that thing
dropped to 15 000 or something that
would be a good place to start putting
money to working again and i'm not
saying it will or won't happen it's just
we're not at the bottom yet of that i'm
sure and so you gotta you gotta you know
hold your nose and wait and see what
happens and in the meantime if you have
a position as i do you just ride it out
i don't use any
leverage in crypto
zero leverage so it can go to zero and
it doesn't wipe me out
crypto is not leverageable yet it needs
to have policy and it has needs to be
regulated and then the volatility
will go down then you can put on some
leverage to goose returns the guys that
put on the leverage are
wiped out and every day you hear another
story
wiped out to zero you got pants on
no no pants on
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right my friend listen i appreciate
you as always coming on where can we
send people to find out more about what
you're doing in bitcoin and crypto well
kevin o'leary tv on every platform you
know linkedin right through to twitter
my fastest-growing platform uniquely
which is so interesting because now a
lot of kryptonians are there is tick
tock who knew are you on tick-tock yeah
you bet i got hundreds of thousands i
just started i'm up to 600 and something
thousand so it's really uh taking off
and it's our fastest growing platform
and that content is unique you have to
produce it as you know make me a promise
hold on make me a promise you don't go
on tick tock have your team post it
cause i can't lose you i don't need you
addicted to tick-tock
i'm on tick-tock every day you know what
i what i try and do is have some fun
with all of this you know it's it's you
gotta you have to realize that
no one knows with certainty particularly
in crypto what's going to happen next
but
we're starting to see and this is really
good in this sense the reason i think we
should all be optimistic probably a
great way to leave this is that every
time you see
a company go to zero that's a broken
business model that's been wiped off
forever no one's going to do the same
thing again everybody's going to learn
from that mistake so
you know i don't want to name the the
zeros but you know who they are they're
happening every day now
when they go to xero it's a good thing
because that business model that amount
of leverage that idea does not return
anytime soon and so the market gets
better and so the remaining assets get
stronger and that's you know my premise
you can see all the work that sam
bankman freida's doing looking at all
these opportunities taking new positions
all over the place he's probably buying
at the bottom in some of these
situations so i think it's a pretty
smart move on his on his side but
there's a guy that understands leverage
i mean he's been in in the trading
business forever and so he understands
risk mitigation some of these other guys
forgot about that and
they're learning a very important lesson
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time